a story broke last night which if true
would be way way bigger really then any
of the news that has surrounded the 2016
presidential campaign and Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton on the one hand we
have allegations that Russia has a
so-called blackmail file on Donald Trump
it includes attempts to sort of uh stage
or frame compromising video of Trump
involving prostitutes it includes
alleged five-year collusion with Russia
and associates of Donald Trump and on
the other hand we have dismissals of the
entire thing as fake news including from
up one corner of the internet the
suggestion that it was all a PSYOP by an
internet message board I'm gonna go
through it start to finish with you we
really need to spend some time on this
because it is totally out of control
it's a story about Trump it's a story
about Russia it's a story about media
and the Internet of course the
background on Russia and Trump we had a
number of connections and suspected
connections between Trump and Russia
Paul Manafort Trump's former former
former campaign manager Russia connected
no doubt about that we have CIA and FBI
agreement that Russia conducted hacking
meant to help Donald Trump after
initially being meant to just hurt
Hillary Clinton eventually as as the CIA
and FBI have told us a number of times
now eventually Russia developed a clear
preference for Donald Trump
how much business does Donald Trump have
with Russia well those are some of the
background issues but let's dig into the
meat of what is being alleged here
yesterday reported by everyone ranging
from the New York Times to CNN to
everything in between that when Donald
Trump finally received that important
now almost infamous I would say briefing
last Friday from our intelligence
agencies about Russian involvement in
the election he was told hey
Russia has a blackmail file as as I'm
sort of calling it on Trump with
damaging information about him Donald
Trump confirmed that he read that and
was given that during a press conference
just hours ago just minutes ago we were
watching the press conference here in
the studio where Donald Trump did say
yes I did receive that briefing from our
Intelligence Agency so next question
where did the information come from and
what does it say I'm going to first tell
you what is being reported and then then
we can look at the narrative of is it
all completely fake is some combination
what's the reality okay veteran
investigative journalist Carl Bernstein
explained the entire process and flow of
the information that's where I want to
start with you today according to Carl
Bernstein and others it's all started
when a retired British mi6 intelligence
agent started preparing opposition
research for a political firm this was
opposition research about Donald Trump
and when this agent started looking at
Donald Trump's business ties some
questionable Russia connections came up
now this is this is our understanding of
how this information was developed so
the former mi6 investigator then did
more research and and actually used his
Russian sources and took what he came up
with to a colleague at the FBI the FBI
colleague took that information to
another FBI agent in Rome and the rome
FBI agent turned all of this information
over to the DC bureau of the FBI
in August of 2016 as we have been told
the story the former British ambassador
to Russia obtained this information and
took it to Senator John McCain a
Republican from Arizona who admittedly
has made no secret about is this taste
for Donald Trump and John McCain uh
claiming to have been unable to
determine the truth of the allegations
took the information to FBI director
James Comey and ultimately the end of
the circle the intelligence agency
he's briefed Donald Trump and President
Barack Obama about the believed
existence of this blackmail file okay
that is the sort of path of the
information this is separate from the
specifics of the information which I
will get to just stay with me if you're
watching on YouTube if you're about to
send me a tweet or leave a comment or
write me an email let's listen and watch
the entire way through before we react
why was Donald Trump told about this
well as we have been told the
intelligence officials were concerned
that the information would leak publicly
before Donald Trump was informed of its
alleged existence that's according to
the officials who of course has spoken
on the condition of anonymity and I will
dig into that a little bit more later so
now that we've understood the path that
these documents and information
allegedly took starting as opposition
research against Donald Trump what is in
the documents and this is really
important we have the documents there is
an alleged 35 page dossier which has
been released Donald Trump is very angry
about its release he has tweeted about
that we'll get to that later what is it
that supposedly Russia has or knows
about Donald Trump let's go to that next
the claims from the leaked so-called
Trump blackmail file are number one that
the Russian government has been trying
to influence Donald Trump for years
number two that Donald Trump has been to
Russia for business many times but
completed no major deals number three
the memos in this supposed 35 page
dossier describe sex videos with
prostitutes and Trump in a 2013 visit to
Moscow to a Moscow hotel this is
something called comprar mats and I've
read about this a lot Pat over the last
few days in with regard specifically to
Trump that the rumors are that it
involves uh urination in a sexual nature
but that that that's sort of like the
most outlandish part of this entire
thing but the concept of compromise is a
known Russian technique used to then
later be able to blackmail people and
that's something that goes well beyond
Trump in it
it's or something you can read about and
I've read quite a bit about it
continuing the leaked Trump blackmail
file file contains supposedly Russian
officials proposing lucrative deals that
were essentially disguised bribes to win
influence over Donald Trump although
again reportedly Trump did not do any of
those deals to his credit I guess he he
wasn't clearly bribed by Russia uh there
are purported meetings that and this is
where it really starts to get where
people are saying if this is true we
have a compromise president there were
purported meetings between Trump
representatives and Russian officials
during the 2016 campaign which would be
absolutely huge topics discussed during
these meetings reportedly include the
hacking of the DNC and John Podesta's
email and lastly that the hacking that
read on 'old Trump now acknowledges
Russia quote probably did that's from
today's press conference look it up
Donald Trump's and yes Russia probably
did the hacking that that hacking
according to this suppose a Trump
blackmail file was carried out with the
quote full knowledge and support of
Donald Trump and his campaign team Wow
so what's the next step Pat we have to
start to examine who said what and what
can be verified right I mean I think
that that's that's where we need to go
next with this yet and I mean if you
look back at the campaign in the
transition these things start to make
sense the reasons why he wouldn't
release his tax returns uh calling out
Hillary for the thirty thousand missing
emails and asking Russian hackers to
release them yeah I mean what you're
pointing out is that the circumstances
match a lot of what is being put out
here but the out the accusations are
fake news depend on that they say hey
you've conveniently built a very
circumstantial case but that's not proof
of anything so now we're gonna start
digging into what we know and what we
could know known knowns unknown knowns
the entire Rumsfeld thing right so Trump
immediately tweeted it's just fake news
period we have the tweet from Donald
Trump saying fake news a total political
witch-hunt
what does Russia say about this well
spokesman for Vladimir Putin the
President of Russia dismissed the
allegations saying
the Kremlin has no compromising dossier
on Trump such information is
inconsistent with reality and nothing
but an absolute fantasy and Russian
officials named in the memo as having
met with Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
this includes about three different
officials they say we haven't met with
Michael Cohen and then another sort of
data point Michael Cohen again who is
Trump's lawyer he is named in this
dossier as having gone to Prague to meet
with Russian agents he said not only did
I not go to Prague to meet with the
Russian agents I've never been to Prague
in my life so then then this gives rise
to the counter narrative right this is a
fake news operation a deliberate one by
internet message boards maybe to trick
corporate media into publishing nonsense
that's the other side right that this is
all it's from the ground up fake
Internet
psyops and message board users on the
message board for Chan are saying hey we
started this whole thing we mailed
something to Rick Wilson and it started
to circulate from there the problem with
that narrative Pat is that nobody is
reporting that Rick Wilson was was part
of the chain of the evidence or of the
alleged evidence here yet even on the
day that this broke there's so much
quickness to call us out as fake news
yeah but you're kind of getting it's a
conspiracy land there you have to think
that the FBI in the CIA and the DNI are
all working together you're building
conspiracies upon conspiracies and I
think we should stick to what we know
and let's at least for now consider the
path of the intelligence to be the the
accurate path and then we can start to
evaluate the content itself now before
we move on to that I want to do I I want
to point out one other tweet from Donald
Trump about this which exposes some
amazing Trump hypocrisy take a look at
this tweet the Donald Trump sent out
where he said intelligence agencies
should never have allowed this fake news
to leak into the public one last shot at
me are we living in Nazi Germany think
about the double standard here for a
second if a foreign government like
Russia leaks information trying to
influence the outcome of the election in
trumps favor
Trump actually praises and encourages
them as Pat mentioned Trump doing about
why doesn't someone hack the rest of
Hillary Clinton's emails but if
Americans or American intelligence or
whoever it is leaks information to try
to protect the integrity of government
right if you believe that Donald Trump
is a Russian puppet that has been up
above guided or harvested by Russian
intelligence for five years all of a
sudden if someone is worried about that
leakers are equivalent to Nazi Germany
does anybody see the hypocrisy here from
Donald Trump right and the others double
standard here is that when Hillary
Clinton gets hacked it's all about the
revelations that came out of those hacks
but Donald Trump gets hacked you know
hacking in the first place is wrong yet
how did the hacking take place is the
concern when the hacking is bad about
Trump let's forget about how it took
place and just focus on the content when
it's Hillary Clinton now I want to
remind you that Mother Jones had an
almost identical report back in October
from David corn called a veteran spy has
given the FBI information alleging a
Russian operation to cultivate Donald
Trump that is the that the same source
right David corn tweeted and we have
David corns tweet one for those asking I
didn't publish the full memos from the
intelligence operative because I could
not confirm the allegation so this is
not even the first time that this
information is circulating last thing
let's now assess what we can about the
stories credibility let's look at the
six points that the American press
Institute gives us for evaluating a
story's credibility number one we need
to know is it a new story or an opinion
piece before we can even evaluate it and
I know this seems very basic but a lot
of people don't get it this has been
reported as a news story okay number two
sources who and what are the sources
cited and why should I believe them the
sources cited are multiple US officials
with direct knowledge of the briefings
as well as Donald Trump Donald Trump has
a confirmed that he did indeed receive
receive the briefing next we need to say
what's the evidence and how is it vetted
and this is where the questions come up
which is we know that the briefing took
place we know that Donald trum
got the information that Russia
allegedly has this information but are
the claims true are the claims true we
do not know that yet and we have to be
very clear about that for interpretation
is the main point of the piece of the
report proven by the evidence well it's
two-sided we now have no reason to doubt
that indeed Donald Trump was made aware
that Russia claims to have this
information or there are claims that
Russia has this information Russia has
now said we don't actually have it but
we don't know whether the information is
true
number five what's missing here well
what's missing is we do not know if the
underlying information is accurate and
number six knowledge am i learning every
day what I need I think with this story
it's good to stick to uh stay off the
message boards Pat and stick to
mainstream or typically credible news
reporting agencies what do I believe
right now about the truth of this I
think there is no doubt that there was
some level of contact or coordination
between some Russian actors and some
Trump campaign individuals we've talked
about that that hasn't changed because
of this story for me I think it is
completely unlikely that in the entire
course of this election there was no
contact between some Trump campaign
staffers and some individuals associated
with Russia now as far as this
supposedly this Trump have some kind of
urine fetish and that there was the this
detail of coordination to try to
blackmail Trump I don't know the answer
to that if this is true it means the
American President may be a hand-picked
puppet of Russia and if true he should
resign but we've got a long way to go
before we know that yeah I think the
most likely scenario is that these leaks
are by and large true and to write it
off as fake news is just the equivalent
of blocking your ears even in our
audience there is a range of people who
say it's completely not true - it's
completely true I think at this point
there's no doubt that Trump received the
briefing we now need to figure out what
actually exists if anything in this
blackmail file hopefully we'll know more
by tomorrow thanks for watching this
video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to a
span the David Pakman show big league as
well as expand progressive activism go
to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated